everything that you understand about
factorizing comes from understanding
expanded because they're the same
process looked at from two different
science okay
so if you're good at expanding you'll be
good at factoring it vice versa so let's
have a look at this one for starters
it's trickier because I'm throwing a
negative in there okay so just to help
you out a little bit it's -5 at the
front it gets distributed to both right
so what pair of terms all I have on the
right hand side for start is minus 5x
and then the minus 5 goes to the 3 as
well so minus 5 times 3 is that's right
minus 15 okay so just pause before we
leave off that now if you saw this as
the question right and the question was
instead of experiment take this which is
already expanded and factorize it right
you would say oh look I see a minus on
both of them right so I can take out a
minus and I see that these are both
multiples of five fives the highest
common factor so I do that right and now
I'll divide each of these terms by -5
when you buy this by minus five you're
just left with an X right an X and when
I divide this by minus five you have the
plus three which is what we started so
far so good
let's extend this out and then we will
have a look at the factorization okay
it's going to distribute across right so
minus four times X gives me minus four X
now here I've got a double negative
right now we have look double negatives
they cancel each other out right so I
should have plus it's wet it down this
is something some of us are getting but
it's still a bit confusing so I want to
go at this point before we look at the
factorization you draw this in a second
this is go to pond table I haven't
filled it in yet okay
the simple idea is for each column and
each row just take those numbers and
multiply and again and see what you get
that's the product okay so some of these
are easier than others for instance
let's have
ah one so that's this column times 1 1
times what is y 1 times 2 is 2 1 times 3
is 3
that's all fine all right I could do the
same thing here this is 1 times 2 which
is 1 times 3 with 3 okay you're starting
to get some patterns right there's some
easy bits over there how about this one
here what's that that's 2 times 2 which
is 4 this is 2 times 3 which is 6
okay next one 2 times 3 is 6 3 times 2
okay so stop before we do the last one
you can see going up here I have
multiples of what going up here are
multiples of 2 so if I say good
multiples of 3 which means lots of balls
over here ok good so I've done this pipe
here now let's have a look at these
parts I put in black I wonder if you can
see why I put me black Yeah right Jordan
what patent do you see they're all equal
0 because this is 0 times something good
0 0 times something else still 0
everything here will be a 0 right and in
the same way this row in the middle it's
0 times something times something blah
blah okay here's where the patent starts
to get interesting right this is this is
obvious this is just positive numbers
and positive numbers ok but to make sure
you understand what's going on in the
rest of the spaces here let's just
follow the pack ok 3 2 2 2 2 1 1 2 0 I'm
counting down I'm taking away one every
time so if I keep taking away one then
here I should add negative 1 right and
then I'll keep going and then I'll keep
going negative 3
now kkeok as I go down I'd take you away
to each time so this will be minus 2
okay you've starting at the idea here I
can do this 1 3 3
six nine three okay excellent
right now it just so happens and you can
fill this out everything over here is
going to get copied over to here okay
I'm still subtracting one as I go from
right to left so this will be - one -
two - three - four okay I'm not gonna
fall in with the rest up here because
you can see what's going on the most
interesting thing and a thing to do this
is what happens over here okay watch hmm
be careful - 4 - 3 - 2 - 1 0 from right
to left
what am i doing each time I'm adding 1
on tired right
- 4 + 1 give minus 3 minus 3 plus 1 will
give you buddies - I had one I add 1 so
what's he up 1 and then I add 1 again
and add 1 again and I can keep going
tonight here I'm not adding 1 I'm adding
2 each time
2 4 6 8 last one very good ok so now
this is why this is so beneficial you
all showed me what to do everyone nailed
the pan it's a really easy pattern but
it shows you for instance minus 2 times
minus 3 two negatives multiplied to give
you a positive right that's why we had a
plus 20 here why do you said - train but
it's not two negatives these are all
negative and these running they are all
positive down here okay so now if I take
this question and I go in reverse just
like report
and I say take this and factorize you
can take this and - for their right
there's no - side there but I can still
divide by a negative number so I'll put
them - for out the front okay when I
divide this by minus 4 I get left with
just just X now I don't divide this by
minus 4 yeah which we saw before that's
why we started make these two negatives
will become that positive this is the
piece you need for exercise 312 right
it's foods chock-full of negatives okay
so you're gonna watch out for them that
these double negatives don't trip you up
the easiest way to test is to take what
you think is the factorization if you
think this is the factorization and then
expand it go in the other way and see
test out if it works and if you pick the
sides correctly then you will check out
okay